ich bin krank aber das hält uns nicht
davon ab auf meinem lieblings
twitter-profil mal vorbeizuschauen babys
beauty meine damen und herren sie kommen
aus köln sie ist beigetreten im februar
2013 und sie ist geboren am 6 februar
1903 wo ich dachte mal die wir auch im
96er jahre lang mal ehrlich noch richtig
hier etwas dazu wenn meine lieblings
youtube in das jetzt auf jeden fall der
twitter-account vom babys beauty palace
sie hat ein wunderschönes titel hier
zusammen mit ihrem freund julian co wir
schauen wir uns mal ihre tweets an würde
ich mal sagen hier haben wir einen
retweet von laura b und j steht für
blanc und job ihr seid verrückt direkt
der erste rechtschreibfehler im zweiten
wort das ist auf jeden fall hammer ich
sehe das sehr häufig auf youtube und
allgemein im internet dass leute seid
mit tier und seit mit die nicht richtig
verwenden können deswegen mal ganz kurz
die erklärung seit mit tief in
verbindung mit der zeit genutzt um seit
mit d
wenn es ein verb ist also haye daumen
hoch wenn ich euer deutschlehrer sein
soll also hier haben wir einen retweet
dann haben wir hier eine entschuldigung
dass ihr video so spät ist hier haben
wir einen retweet von ihrem freund und
zwar recht herzlichen dank bibi für
diese äusserst leerzeichen vergessen
julian cope äußerst unangenehme
trottelige wasser um stück aktionen und
dabei hat sie auch noch ein bisschen
scheiße und ein bisschen weiße farbe war
deine hose geschüttet aber ich meine
damen und herren das sind ja alles ganz
normale tweets von meiner lieblings
youtube bianca hein können oder
irgendwie so und ich als babynator
wirklich von poe bis kopf von nase bis c
nagel
er hat mir gesagt okay ich liebe deine
baby über alles und ich respektiere sie
komplett für das was sie für uns für die
bina toren tut gut so dass man leichter
wenn ich schnell wieder gesund werden
soll jahren 100.000 3 millionen likes
auf jeden fall habe ich zwischen all
ihren 11.900 tweets wie kann man so viel
treten da habe ich dann schmid gefunden
wo ich mir wirklich gedacht haben
normalerweise liebe ich meine bianca
heineken über alles aber bei dem tvi
dass mir echt ja super habe mein handy
gerade mal seit 1 tag und schon ist ein
komischer pixelfehler dann nicht mehr
weggeht so denkt man sich im ersten
moment erstmal okay den schmied kann man
so eigentlich stehen lassen also baby
teilt uns hiermit dass sie ein neues
iphone ixxat also das sieht man gleich
auf dem foto das ist eine von nächstes
und dieses handy hat schon nach wenigen
tagen einen pixelfehler das ist ja
eventuell hingefallen oder keine ahnung
was und dementsprechend ist die hardware
vom handy beschädigt worden was ist der
unterschied zwischen einem hardware
fehler und einem software fehler
ein softwarefehler es beispielsweise
wenn sich eine app nicht mehr öffnen
lässt oder wenn man nicht mehr richtig
telefonieren kann und das telefonat
abbricht an irgend einer bestimmten
stelle ein hardware fehler
beziehungsweise problem ist dann
beispielsweise denn irgendein rissen der
kamera ist man dementsprechend nicht
mehr richtig fotos machen kann oder wenn
der home-button beschädigt ist und man
nicht mehr das handy entsperren kann
oder halt auch ein pixelfehler wenn mir
als beispielsweise mein handy hinfällt
und das hat einen komplett riesigen
kratzer und das ganze display ist
gesprungen und ich würde sagen hey yo yo
hin und kollege von mir hier kommen
displays der bodenschicht im screenshot
der lacht mich aus weil auf dem
screenshot sieht man keine hardware
fehler bibi hat das nicht so verstanden
die sagt dass sie einen pixelfehler hat
der nicht mehr weggeht und naja wien
man sieht diesen pixelfehler nicht weil
das ein hardware probleme sich als
babynator meine damen und herren
als ich diesen tweet von wiwi gelesen
habe habe ich mir gedacht wie wir hatten
bestimmt so viel stress in ihrem leben
und hat so viel zu tun und so viele
menschenleben zu retten der ist es
vielleicht einfach nicht aufgefallen
dass man einen pixelfehler jetzt nicht
über einen screenshot irgendwie den
leuten mitteilen kann
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
schauen mal was die leute so in den
kommentaren schreiben und sagen den
beziehungsweise überzeugen die davon das
baby klug ist und das wusste aus wut
über diesen schritt habe ich mein handy
eingeschlagen schaut euch den fetten
riss auf meinem display an danke baby
mensch finde ich aber jetzt nicht okay
dass hier das hier aufgrund des risses
von dir und dem pixelfehler auf wie es
handy habe ich mein eigenes
fallengelassen bti den riss und den
pixelfehler freunde jetzt macht die bibi
immer nicht so fertig bbv is love you
talking
jetzt kam ich auf jeden fall noch einige
andere an und haben den witz quasi
aufgegriffen also aufgrund eines risses
und eines wechselfehlers hat sich mein
akku aufgeregt mein handy lag jetzt
wegen euch hab jetzt nicht schutzfolie
drauf habe mit edding auf die
schutzfolie gemahl daher geht nicht mehr
ab seht ihr das hier meine damen und
herren hat ebenfalls eine andere
babynator in kommentiert und zwar wo
denn mensch die hat wohl auch so viel zu
tun wie bibi und weiß nicht dass wir
schauen uns mal ihre bio an und zwar
steht da drin auch blow und job die
schreibt auf jeden fall wo denn sie hat
den pixelfehler also anscheinend nicht
auf dem screenshot von bibi erkannt
elend präsenter schreibt oh nein lauras
streit und willst du hin gefahren was
laura bist du komplett bild also ich
meine bisher eine wie naturen bist du
komplett tollen dein herz sein aber du
auf den kopf ganz hart sogar 718 gefällt
mir
alter schwede
neben muss ich nicht ich wollte gefällt
mir nicht machen wenn ich mir so dein
profilbild
trachte muss ich mir eher gedanken
darüber machen dass du trasse auf den
kopf gefallen bist und das nicht nur
einmal das ist komplett falsch dieser
ganze satz ja was hast du gegen mein
aussehen laden hat nichts mit dem
aussehen zu tun eher mit denen
bildansicht da ist schon wieder ein
kompletter grammatik wieder drin
also ich habe die aussage komplett
gefeiert von dem typen aber sein twitter
bild es ist in der tat ein bisschen
komisch geboren 1955 alles klar
der guard das stimmt definitiv aber ich
würde sagen meine damen und herren wir
schauen uns noch mal ein paar weitere
tweets unter dem haupt beat von genial
bliebe baby auf einem screenshot sieht
man keine display fehler nur so als tipp
ganz liebe grüße 2100 likes jamann
ach du heilige scheiße was das für eine
antwort wenn man richtig lesen würde
dann würde man auch sehen dass ihr handy
eine pixelfehler hat und keine display
fehler alles klar da ist jemand komplett
auf den kopf gefallen
komischerweise sind pixelfehler display
fehler ja genau das gleiche für bianca
watson hat jetzt auch sagen wenn ein
handy einen pixelfehler hat dann ist es
nicht etwa also ein pixel des hardware
das in pixel also hey ich bin ja selber
auch babynator pixelfehler sind nicht
eher display fehler aber jetzt wird hier
richtig gemein zurückgeschlagen hier
wird gerade die bio von der bianca
botzenhardt gepostet und ja da drin
stehen ich bin glücklich vergeben und
das schreibt eine person einfach er tut
mir leid also ich meine es ist schon na
ja ich will da nichts zu sagen sonst
kommen nach ähnlichen news youtuber an
und nehme ich wiederhole auch ein guter
kommentar unterwegs kritis einbildung
ist auch eine bildung finde ich aber
gemein weil die bianca ist zusammen mit
julian kuhn in meinem herz ich glaube
ich bin zu doof den zu sehen dass wieder
die laura wie das idol so der fan
vielleicht sbb uns auch einfach so
verlegen dass sie ihre ganze dummheit
und spielt und insgeheim über uns alle
lacht weil wir das auch noch abkommen
alter könnte es sein das baby das extra
gemacht hat um zu schauen ob wir denken
dass sie wirklich dass er so klug ist
sie nicht lasst alles daran ihr wollte
dass ich gesund werde dann 50 3
millionen 1000 leicht wenn das ein
ernstes so bleibst du deine pixelfehler
finde ich gemein weil baby ist meine
göttin wenn sich unternehmen dieses
video angucken möchte kein unternehmen
mehr mit mir eine kooperation machen
habe gerade einen 2 euro stücke auf mein
handy gelegt hier ein screenshot davon
damit ihr es alle sehen können
lasst sie in ruhe alia lohan job für
verschiedene
alter als wenn das für bibi und julian
steht also ich meine ich als babynator
in weiß natürlich dass b und j nicht für
blumen job steht sondern für bibi und
julian und also schreibe ich jetzt auch
in meinen twitter-account luca pizza.de
und j so ich bin auch offiziell kein
wunder wieso deine fans zu dumm sind
hallo ich bin nicht um 40 milliarden
likes wenn ich gesund werden soll warum
tut dummheit nicht weh weil sie dann
stündlich eine 600 übernehmen müsste
luke youtube pixel arrows screenshot ono
ist rita hey man babys süß ich würde
sagen wir beenden die ganze reaction mit
der einem kommentar von mars bett und
zwar einfach nur ein trauriger smiley
das fast es für mich auch zusammen weil
ich bin großer fan und beine darüber wie
diese ganzen klugen menschen über meine
göttin lachen
das war es jetzt der familie meine damen
und herren wenn euch meine wäsche
gefallen hat das gerne mal ein leib da
und wenn ihr wollt ist wieder gesund
werde laste 10 lifestar bitte versteht
dass das hier alles nicht ernst gemeint
ist wie du kannst persönlich der
netteste mensch der welt sein aber was
zu teilweise so von dir gibst es einfach
wirklich pure dummheit ich möchte hier
niemanden hätten
bildet euch selber ein bild von
bestimmten leuten aber ich fand die
kommentare unter dem total lustig
deswegen habe ich gedacht da muss ich
eigentlich mal drauf reagieren heute ist
mittwoch der 22 november das nächste
woche freitag am ersten 12
de botton fünf neue produkte ein t
shirts weiß wetter ein rudi und socken
zum allerersten mal mache ich
tatsächlich socken ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn ihr da nächste woche freitag
mal vorbeischaut um 15 uhr launischen
die sachen und jetzt meine damen und
herren kommt das auto glas wasser ziel
vom bio das war es jetzt hier vom video
hier können jetzt jemanden kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnenten
können die auf die glocke klicken dann
bekommen die winde nach richtungen
[Musik]